how are you Scott I'm well rich thanks
thanks for having me it's been too long
it has been way too long
and has been um Congrats on moving the
Sports Center that means a lot I'm sure
to you thank you it does it's it's
exciting it's excited to be able to kind
of talk about it because it's been in
the hopper for a while and um you know
you you keep these things close to the
vest and now that we can discuss it it's
just it's exciting to get home to the
family friends the area we're all from
somewhere as I often say that's wrong
wrong and I didn't know that I could get
back there but the fact that my boss is
all the way up to the top that Jimmy
pitar there's a mensch we're willing to
entertain the thought and and ultimately
green light it is it's just massive
manage a total total game changer for me
I'm thrilled to hear that you deserve it
and I'm glad that uh that Jimmy potaro
and the rest of Management said yes to
that you were so kind to call me after
my dad passed Scott and your mom's 80
right she's 80 years old yep he'll be
yep she'll be 80 that summer so for you
to go and she lives in the area right so
for you to go and work there and have
your kids go to her house and Sheeta
there's you know yours and there's
nothing like it man yeah good for you
I think this stuff and you know I mean
we can talk sports but you know I'll
tell you this yeah I did I did reach out
you after after you podcast but it was
it was cathartic for me too and and
there's a lot of people out there that
are in that Club but we all had your
back and we all have each other's backs
and now we get through those tough times
so that was that was memorable man I was
I was a beautiful moment between friends
and I was I was uh you know it meant a
lot to me too but I bring it up only
because here it is great again and we
will talk sports to be able to do
something you know and have a family
moment and be able to to put your
professional spot where it can actually
enhance your personal it's just it's so
rare and that in the TV business State
people say let's do it
Plus is a great idea man it's I mean DC
is
where a lot of people obviously the
professional teams come through and
you're gonna probably a lot more in
studio guests than you then you've had
up there in Connecticut I would think I
would think I mean certainly are the
opportunities to cross paths with people
is there's been on the ground in Bristol
as you know so much like you know much
like where you are it's a different
different kind of cross-section I
suppose of who comes through there but
more and we look forward to however the
things might change and I look forward
to how just personally as you said being
around being around family won't look
will change the whole vibe just in life
and ultimately it's our life that
matters what you and I are lucky to do
we love ya but but we love more datings
our family so that that'll put me there
and again a little part of me is jealous
because my suggestion of do SportsCenter
and move it to Staten Island New York
went over like a lead balloon about 20
years ago man just uh I shouldn't you
know I said you know I said to him I'm
like look we can't have Steven Seagal
come in you know Alyssa Milano a Rick
Schroder gonna have Rick Schroder come
in yeah wu-tang clan I mean they would
have been amazing
could you imagine sports oh my gosh I
would I got I've got more lines than
Stewart let's let's talk sports now
Scott Van Pelt let's get to it right
here the most I guess the best biggest
storyline to come out of the NFL playoff
so far in your mind would be fill in the
blank right there wouldn't be Dan to
city's explosion I mean down 24 to a pit
to have I mean you try to frame it and
there's a lot that went into it
obviously I mean there's some decisions
to get made some that are conservative
some that are aggressive from the Texan
side but then it's just it's the
capacity from the homes in that offense
to to it you know explode like that what
they had a 28-point quarter and against
the Raiders earlier this year
but to do it in a playoff game like that
and to totally take what appeared to be
a dead no water game and and flip that
script you know that that's that's huge
and then you combine it with I suppose
the 1a which is which is the presumed
MVP having a second consecutive top
playoff game
Tennessee going in there and winning
back the games a new one and then over
the ones he did called him watch to me
das he gave us the most compelling
storylines from the weekend
San Francisco Green Bay sure I'm signed
up for that gave me give me that for
sure I'm just saying to come out of the
weekend you know history made in Kansas
City and the fact that Tennessee and it
wasn't accident rich like they won that
game because they they went in and they
largely bullied Baltimore that was that
was not anything I think a lot of people
saw coming well I guess you hit on
something that I mentioned in the first
hour which is the I guess the the Lamar
isn't all that camp that we heard so
much about
throughout the summer is now after 17
stellar regular-season weeks or 16
because he sat out week 17 enough to win
win himself the MVP award that we're
gonna see the night before the Super
Bowl the those those folks have come out
of the woodwork again I'm not here for
it I think the kids dynamic and is in
fact the type of player that we're gonna
see more and more teams draft or more
and more teams try and emulate I'm
wondering what you think on this subject
you know you know the world we occupy at
the moment rich I mean it's it's nuanced
subtlety just appreciation for how hard
it is to win that all goes out the
window so that we can make these
absolute declarations you're either the
best or you suck and he either was I
guess I guess an entire year's worth of
evidence is what flushed because of a
difficult night I mean and by the way
like last year and I owned this on
SportsCenter about 25 times and we had
coach Harbaugh on and and he kind of
laughed at me I said when did you know
that he was going to be what he is and
he said sooner than you did evidently
because I told them last year in the
playoffs he completed three passes
through three quarters against the
chargers and I'm like well this guy
can't do this and then he gave us the
year that
he gave us and and it's hard to win
playoff games really really hard and so
I like you I'm not here for this if you
want to you want to chatter about what
he's not going to be then then have fun
writing me obit for the 23 year old
quarterback who I'm guessing will
probably win playoff games if not a
Super Bowl before it's over but here's
the thing about winning a Super Bowl
look how hard look how hard rich Drew
Brees has won Aaron Rodgers has won
there's some of the greats that have
ever played the position so I just admit
that trying to diminish a season's worth
of accomplishment because of 60 minutes
of football that's dumb
but if people in a big fat race to be
dumb then have fun winning that race
Scott Van Pelt here on the Richardson
show I'll ask you the question I get
I've truly gotten more than who do you
think's winning the Superbowl over the
last several weeks at dinner parties are
just walking around or whatever what he
thinks you nap with Tom Brady the number
of p.m. because maybe you're going it
started smile because I'm like it's the
brady question it's gotta be right and
he keep is the great source of curiosity
I know where I land on this I cannot
close my eyes and envision him in
another jersey other than the pain
because I can't imagine Robert Kraft
allowing it to be right I mean given all
that they've done together to let to
have him be Montana in a Chiefs jersey
Emmitt Smith and a Cardinals jersey
Jerry Rice in whichever jersey atella
was it I can't remember was a Seattle or
Oakland but it wasn't Niners I can't see
that as the as the last image we have I
can't see his last pass in New England
being a big six against the Titans so in
my brain I I can't see it and yet this
is a proud guy who for the first time in
his professional life truly has his
hands on the wheel and can drive
wherever he wishes to go and so if he
finds a circumstance a situation that he
thinks gives him a better path then then
it wouldn't it wouldn't shock me did he
take it
I just I think that would only happen if
New England allows him to consider it
and and I can't imagine that
that were you and really yes work here's
where I land on it I think one of the
reasons why I get it a lot out here in
LA is that there's a lot of LA sports
fans that are clearing oh yeah and it
would and and trust me they could really
use them with the ultimate of respect to
Phillip Rivers in terms of filling up a
new stadium my kids would instantly want
powder-blue Brady jerseys on the spot if
that actually happened here's the issue
is that yes that that yes you're right
Robert Kraft would never want that to
happen and I think deep down Brady
doesn't want it to happen
Belichick I don't know if he's looking
over the steering wheel and saying hey
at some point we've got to get ourselves
an idea about what we're doing over the
next two to five six years is certainly
since that's what he has left one would
think as a coach but the the the the
deadlines the way this all works out is
he needs to make this decision this has
to be done by March 18th newley gear
otherwise they he counts thirteen and a
half million dollars on the cap period
it's what he counts in terms of of being
either cut or traded and then if he
stays then obviously they want it he
wants to get paid a significant amount
of money after that then the thirteen
and a half millions already counted
towards his salary that might be an
issue but the reason why I bring all
this up is by then the issue of well who
else is playing with me still can't be
answered it's all got to be trust us and
and I don't know what he's gonna sit
there and think certainly if he has
through other potential channels a clear
indication he could move out to Southern
California and play out his playing days
here that's going to be when listening
which comes to shopping you said it
everything you said is entirely
reasonable I'm Brady all that we've
accomplished together in New England I
would say to rob a crab Bill Belichick
etc let's look at this list of folks we
had this year that isn't good enough
right because it wasn't and and the
opportunity to play where the board and
an actor and an Allen and a Henriot and
a Williams etc okay I mean I think
that's that's I mean not for nothing it
that's it that's a better group stopper
past because you got to play two games
against mahomes and you know I got that
Buffalo's on the uptick etc
you know they've dominated a division
forever I mean they've had a much easier
path in the east and then anywhere else
so I don't know it's all fascinating
just because again just to get the
dismount right and that's one of the
hardest things in sports to do and so
few of the Great's get it right and by
right I mean for us you know it's for
them it's all that really matters but
for us for it to feel like the
appropriate ending where you go yeah
that that feels right I mean that's
gonna be really really curious and it's
fascinating that word gets overused but
it's fascinating to think about what
Grady does next last one for you Scott
Van Pelt what happens tonight what do
you think happens tonight in new New
Orleans and on your network they got
rece Davis calling in an hour 3s getting
set to host it what do you think happens
this evening between LSU and Clemson
when I talked to Chris Fowler last night
he did a great job of letting me and our
viewers understand something that both
teams that they sat down to are not
confident they are supremely confident
it's rare that both teams arrive to a to
a field for a game where each has the
right to feel overwhelming arrogance
about who they are and one of them is
going to be wrong and Clemson hasn't
lost in 29 games they've won 769 out of
the last 73 games typically uh so they
they have every right to feel the way
they feel and Dabo gets to go in as an
underdog and he loves love's love's that
I just I can't see LSU this year with
that quarterback in that state in that
building I can't see him losing tonight
I think it's going to be a back and
forth like Rocky fight I really do and I
think in the end LSU's got more but I I
just
I'm shrugging only because I can't
remember a game where I think both teams
truly deserve to feel like they walk in
there like the baddest the baddest team
on the field so I mean that's our hope
as a network and for fans of the sport
that we get it but I really think we
will you're so naughty LSU wins you're
so not wrong in the fact about both
teams have every right to be arrogant
huh I don't know the name of this young
man but I read an article about the one
quarterback who beat Trevor Lawrence in
high school because he's the only
quarterback to ever beat Trevor Lawrence
and Joe burrow would get his name to
that list of that guy his name is a top
and I don't know his name but it's
unbelievable and and you know scouts are
gonna be all over this game because it's
the next two overall first overall draft
choices the next - for sure 20/20 or
Twitter 21 it is their yeah 15 seconds
to you to give you an attaboy well just
the NFL show you guys did with with
Belichick Collinsworth and the crew just
just it was it was like insatiable
appetite for it I wanted more I wanted
you to do 450 or just do 500 players or
at Belichick if he says pooch punters I
wanted I mean and I was so glad that
people got to see that version of coach
Belichick he's in there he took very
close to the vest but when he truly is
engaged and interested and you did a
great job of you know just facilitating
all that thank you you couldn't have
asked for more and you guys were awesome
thank you
yeah one of our favorite moments of
shooting that was when Belichick was
talking about Johnny Unitas because it
was time to talk about Johnny you and he
said that he was at Jionni use youth
camp you attended it as a member of
Johnny use youth camp and he said
however he didn't catch passes from
Johnny
he was his team's center so he snapped
passes to Johnny Unitas and later on
that night at dinner and there's a whole
bunch of us there in Collinsworth
sitting to my right
Belichick wasn't there but because
there's a long day of shooting and he
had come from a long way we all agreed
that was the most Belichick thing he
could have said or did say the entire
day of the first shoot of all four
episodes that he snapped the ball to
Johnny Unitas and then sure enough in
the six months you give NFL Films 6
months to sprinkle their sable fairy
dust in the Edit Bay they found a
picture of Belichick snapping - Johnny
you which I saw for the first time when
they they aired the quarterback show
it's unbelievable it was unbelievable
I'm so glad you uh you enjoyed it as
much as you did well everybody did and
they're great you all are great it's
cotton
it was say it was fantastic kudos all
the way around everybody and especially
all the people behind the scenes because
as you and I both know nothing that we
do is great without the hundreds of men
and women behind us there
dropping us up so kudos to all of them
there was sensation right back at you
Scott thanks for the call again Congrats
on moving the SportsCenter will chat way
before that obviously I hope still pal
be well all the best
right back at you Scott Van Pelt at not
the fake SVP for more of the Rich Eisen
show tune - audience Channel 239 under
red TV for free on BR live or download
the Rich Eisen show app